she's the counselor to president Trump
Kellyanne Conway is with us Kellyanne
the one thing that really well two
things struck me today as Mick Mulvaney
was talking and speaking to the press
number one how ignorant Jim Acosta it is
that you need 60 votes and number two he
said you this does not have to be
painful Obama and the Democrats made it
more painful than it needed to be that
will not be the case this time look at
the different approach of this president
from the former president he was
entertaining negotiations listening to
people very patiently today I witnessed
some of it and this president has said
from the beginning that he supports a
longer-term deal you've got the
Democrats now on the wrong side of
history with the tax cuts which already
have yielded millions of Americans
benefiting from pay raises and bonuses
and capital investments and repatriation
of wealth if you voted against the tax
cut last month you voted against 20,000
jobs from Apple this month and the same
thing is happening out the Democrats
tonight are on the wrong side of history
they're against veterans and children
our Border Patrol agents are
firefighters there against the Pentagon
when our Secretary of Defense says that
military readiness is in peril so you've
got Donald Trump our president very
cleverly having the Democrats be against
chip at children's health a plan which
will imperil many many children who rely
upon that all we're asking for is a
longer-term deal that funds our military
that gets that wall the border security
the president said he'll talk about tax
on there's a debt there's a deadline
approaching tonight but the deadlines
not daca that's in March the deadline
tonight is a spending bill you have a
more government open and and you're
started by the way you're starting to
see you're starting to see some
Democrats peel off they're not willing
to go down with a sinking ship
that the I think the more left-wing
folks who are auditioning for 2020 are
trying to steer the Democratic Party
into you see some of those red state
Democrats tonight peeling off from the
leadership and saying they can support
this bill all right you know look this
is so important on so many different
levels not the least of which is we're
gonna have Border Patrol agents they
have to work but they may not get paid
that's right that's hurting you know the
Forgotten men and women the
people that do all these great jobs for
us firemen etc if it's only till
February 8th and Chuck Schumer does he
not know that they don't have control of
this and that he is trying to weaponize
and and threaten the American people
with the big shutdown because that's the
language that he used on Pelosi used
just five years ago well the answer to
your question was said by many Democrats
publicly on TV and elsewhere today Sean
many democratic office holders and
pundits and sympathizers took to the
airwaves and said oh well the
Republicans will be blamed for this they
control the house the Senate the White
House first of all you need 60 votes
secondly that's the wrong way of looking
at this because there's only one major
party and one major movement for the
last year-plus
that has claimed the mantle of quote
resistance and America knows who that is
the Democrats pride themselves on
obstruction and resistance saying no and
holding up a stop sign so people will
know the same folks who resisted giving
the Forgotten men and Forgotten women
tax cut last month are getting in their
way of those who live paycheck to
paycheck of getting that paycheck they
know the pay this is the Paycheck
President Donald Trump versus folks who
are be so petty about daca before the
deadline even is upon us that they would
deny people their paychecks and that
really is regrettable I hope they change
their mind and I hope they see toward
toward the the I think the value of
keeping the government open all right
Kellyanne we thank you but we were
watching by the way the